willkommen zum glück muss tag nummer 23
33 heute ist der zweite dezember ihr
seht es am dritten dezember ein bisschen
verwirrend aber okay heute geht's
vielleicht zu ikea und vielleicht werden
kekse gebacken
wir sind uns da noch nicht so sicher wie
der tag heute aussehen wird und ich muss
diese lichterkette mal umstellen die
macht diese ganze zeit dieses flackern
verschiedenes licht kann ja verschiedene
der kamera aussehen und das sieht auf
jeden fall sehr crazy aus ich rede
gerade über die lichterkette an meinem
adventskalender apropos adventskalender
wir machen jetzt das zweite türchen auch
ich habe den ganzen morgen wieder
geschnitten und das video hochgeladen
das kommt um 17 uhr online also jetzt an
und jetzt fängt erst so richtig mein tag
für mich an und es ist irgendwie komisch
völlig heute stellung ist 36
aufgestanden bin um dann den block zu
schneiden
jetzt machen wir das zweite türchen arms
ich weiß nicht was ich für ein outfit
tragen
irgendwie eine geschmacklich heute was
cooles anziehen
ein bisschen eure taut die jacke ich
fand sie ganz cool im laden und ich
kaufe mir eigentlich nie jacken aber die
ist so ein bisschen keine ahnung so ist
es ist ein statement okay obwohl in der
letzten excuse me im letzten türchen
hatte ich eine achtsamkeit dass man
normale aufgaben mit mehr bewusstsein
machen soll und die noch einmal so ganz
bewusst spüren soll
und irgendwas habe ich gespürt jetzt
weiß ich als ich heute morgen um 36
aufgestanden bin hab ich mich als kurz
gestreckt und dann habe ich an diese
karte gedacht nachdem ihr sohn ein
streck dich mal richtig bewusst und das
war s so gut weil ich also mich in alle
richtung gestreckt habe meinen kopf hin
und her gestreckt hab dann die arme so
richtig aus gedreht habe und danach als
mein körper wirklich besser angefügt
also probiert es aus morgens euch
richtig ordentlich zu strecken als ob
wichtige aufgabe am tag werden oreo
kekse sind drin
soll das eine botschaft seien irgendwie
bewusste hand wahrnehmung verschränken
deine hände ganz fest miteinander und
halte sie für fünf bis zehn sekunden in
dieser position lassen sie dann los
achte darauf wie sich das anfühlt rede
dich so lange wie möglich das gefühl ich
[Musik]
sei schlecht gegen mario keks aber
einfach nur weil du die klassischen
kalender eh schon ausgepackt hat und die
krasseste kalender für behält
es ist gerade gehört aber das den
auspackt 1 ori okay so gespielt wie
kultur kann nicht fair dass sie
aufgeholt und keine schoko statt
überall wo ich habe heute ein gutschein
geschenkt ein müll runterbringt hast du
lust hast du schon gezeigten
kalenderjahr hat zu dürfen
ich gucke auch nach oben rein
egoistischer arsch ist ein offizier
dafür aussieht
narzissmus ein sehr ausgeprägter gewürze
zum inspektor damit trug er ja so wollen
wir dann noch mal egal
yahoo
der pony wird wieder so lange aber ich
kann es nicht schneiden weil immer wenn
ich schneide verschneiden ich mich und
meine friseurin friseusen friseurin
sind köln wie sie sehen hören können ist
meine waschmaschine an aber ich bin ich
jetzt schon fertig machen und das ist
ganz lustig mal zu filmen dann könnt ihr
sehen was ich so mache
[Musik]
zuerst tragen wir unser viel zu
überteuert ascent die im make up auf nun
unbedingt in berlin gibt so einen
koreanischen judy salon und ich musste
unbedingt mal hingehen weitermachen so
koreanische methoden und koreanische
masse und ich glaube an die koreanische
beauty müsste wenn die eigens können
dann ist das gut dann nehme ich meinen
pinsel und macht so dr web clip der pid
mein gesicht meine haut es ist
unglaublich den concealer unter die
augen verteilen und schön in das auge
rein reiben so dass es richtig schnell
fertig wird das ist wichtig und weil
meine nägel wirklich so schrecklich aus
sein habe ich mich dazu entschieden den
nagellack endlich ab zu machen oder noch
schöne nagelknipser naja das ist content
leute
[Musik]
also wenn ich jetzt gerade so auf meine
fingernägel schaue die sehen immer noch
schrecklich aus aber wenigstens kann ich
jetzt so in ein nagelstudio gehen ohne
im boden zu versinken eine fingernägel
sind wieder wie von einem menschen
zuerst trage ich den prima auf und nehme
dann meine anastacia beverly hills
lidschatten palette und zwar die
norweger weil mir meine modern remote
sense am flughafen köln/bonn abgenommen
wurde
natürlich benutze ich als curry
exzentrik exzentrik er das orange alt
dann nehme ich meine so ewer karamell
melanie palette und reibt mein finger in
das orange glitzer da drin
ich sag mal so wenn man täglich make up
tragen will dann muss das design und
schnell und einfach unkompliziert und
ich finde man kann auch schöne lux
einfach mit wenig wissen und talent
kreieren
und fehlende wangenknochen kann man auch
mit konnte ring hätten um meine
augenbrauen aufzufüllen benutze ich
anastasia beverly hills augenbrauen
pampe manchmal bürste ich dann auch mit
seiner braunen augenbrauen mascara meine
augenbrauen male meine wangen rosa an
als waschechter karibu mal ich meine
lippen so an dass sich in der mitte ein
bisschen rosa mache und dann mit einem
lipgloss drüber gehe und dass alles
verteile ich finde das gibt einen
schönen effekt und sieht sehr natürlich
aus
zum abschluss gibt es dann natürlich
noch eine schicht mascara um drauf und
dann bin ich auch schon fertig
wunderschön und ready für den tag so
genetisches mal finale locker ich bin
sehr zufrieden aber ich werde noch
einmal mein outfit wechseln weil ich
befreie jetzt im winter bei drei grad
nicht so cool finde ihr dürft aber den
anblick nicht verpassen hier
ich hab vergessen das zweite türchen vom
adventskalender zumal auf zu machen
bevor wir nämlich zu ikea fahren
das muss ja nicht in der richtigen ikea
werbung werden natürlich beide zürcher
[Musik]
bist du der kameramann firma bist du es
ich werde davon say verstopfung kriegen
laktose lass mich los du bloß nichts
falsch ist die kameraleute behandlung
für mich so mega ungewohnt einfach
geflohen sobald die kamera stimmen dass
ich noch immer versteckte doppelsitz
frei aber ich frieden haben da bleiben
konnte dass die auch nicht immer glauben
dass da wirklich wahr ist doch auch ganz
direkt die haben man konnte doch oder
hannah an der entscheidung seine ferien
gezweifelt ob ich jetzt aber mal ich
muss mal ganz kurz und regelwerk
reinschauen sorgte bekommen
drei seien ja alles klar okay ich bin
frei
aber auch so eine grauzone die wieder
angewendet haben patrick 17
also ok du musst jetzt hier geradeaus
dann rechts und lebensrecht links noch
mal links und dann ganz lange geradeaus
noch mal links und noch mal rechts zu
begleichen
da ist ein mann annette paradise
argumenten ist ein zirkus zirkus
das ist ein riesen ja mein gott da gehen
wir noch hin oder können wir das den
ost-renten ghost rider fahren herrmann
und jetzt da geht es gleich oh mein gott
ich habe so eine schöne aufnahme und und
ab die post
wir machen jetzt schöne pärchen zeit
also wir machen jetzt schöne pärchen
zeit ikea und gönnen uns einen dicken
hot dog in die fresse lupenrein
also wir haben ein schönes risotto mit
hartkäse und noch eingeholt
kamenz
ich turne maximale gewinn und irgendwann
war schon fest
erholt
das risotto commons meiner lesung lima
von latin
helens gonna hate was lustig
moritz fragen zum 3 ich meine dass in
dort kerzen adventskränze eine große
kleine mittlere david mcallister
matheaufgabe wie viele von den kerzen
braucht damit man die adventskränze mit
vier auffüllen kann und keine kerze
übrig bleibt
das heißt mit nur zwei von den kaufs
hast du jetzt zwei übrig weil du dann
hier also nach der sechs kerzen genau so
nah so zwei übrig wenn du noch ein
klarer kauf
also man braucht vier packungen
focus prozent der wagen nicht
hat jemand sage klar
hier trifft sich das iaea team immer zum
meeting als wir haben dort eine vision
dafür brauchen wir und eine strategie
die gute argumente gut aber wir haben
gute argumente
und dann haben wir eine strategie die
uns wieder zu einer version für
argumente ja finde ich auch
die idee marketing dafür stehen mit
unserem namen
[Musik]
25 leute das mit 5
jemand wie viele kerzen an den brauchen
wir um alle volkmann
also und 20 haben wir das ist die
packungen
diese nahm diese über eine sowie mahner
auf wir haben da auch mal zu gewinnen
man hat so zieht der zubau frühen 20
übrigens heute abend essen zurück im
auto und zum jahrmarkt geben wir glaube
ich nicht mehr da sieht hier ganz nach
platzregen aus
[Musik]
das große buch der weiner die schönsten
geschichten von astrid lindgren
kirsten boie cornelia funke baumer und
viele mehr
mixa pause
da ich nicht gewohnt bin um 36
aufzustehen musste ich einen vorschlag
vor dem haupt schlafen verachten
ich habe etwas gemacht was ich noch nie
gemacht habe und zwar habe ich bei ikea
von der süßigkeiten wand wo man sich
sehr gute typen machen kann einmal jedes
ding in meine tüte gepackt ich habe das
gefühl sie ist leerer als sonst
wenn ich einfach so mir süßigkeiten
daraus wurde dann mache ich sie voller
aber jetzt durfte ich halt oder hab nur
von jedem eingenommen das ist aber nicht
das einzige
die haben ja diese szene monroe bands
dinger und jetzt haben sie die mit
gingerbread geschmack des pools co ich
glaube die gibt es sonst auch mit einem
anderen geschmack und jetzt ist zeit mit
dem kabarett geschmack also alles sehr
weihnachtlich mein gott noch eine sache
sie vergessen
auch diese wie kleiner
hier haben wir in süßen dann war
[Musik]
schaum zuckerwaren sind okay aber was
mir sofort auffällt und werde ich auf
jeden fall benutzen um so ein
lebkuchenhaus dann das musste ich auch
nicht
nicht mehr künstlich
um schmecken wieder nicht doch sehr
weihnachten immer sehr elegant wie kann
ich empfehlen die habe ich vorher auch
noch nie gegessen hatte ich werde jetzt
die christmas version als erstes um
ihren sohn schoko drop mit karamell
gefällt keine ahnung woher diese station
plötzlich kam
ich glaube ich bin heute fünf mal auf so
ehlers youtube account gegangen um zu
gucken ob sie ihre blogs schon
hochgeladen hat weil es einfach für mich
zu weihnachten zeigt dazu gehört ihre
glocke sachen zu schauen auch wenn ich
manchmal einfach durchs kippe und sachen
überspringen weil sie unglaublich
langsam schneidet also sie lässt er
jedes jede pause drin jedes räuspern
alles aber sie hatte nichts hochgeladen
das habe ich damit ist der video drehen
ich drehe damit lasse mehr video kanal
noch nicht kennt der ein bisschen nett
ist so teilweise lautsprecher linken
euch unten oder unten also dann zeige
ich euch mal was ich noch bei ikea
gekauft hat für dieses jahr
ich brauchte ein neues geschenkpapier
das ist ganz gut eigentlich mit so
beißen schneemann und blauen bergen und
so
wie sich meine ich finde es schön das
ist so schlicht und ich mag es nicht so
fit ist dann für den tannenbaum weil ich
noch keine richtigen weihnachtskugeln
hab ich mir ein set weihnachtskugeln
geholt in rot und ein bisschen weiß
warum habe ich eine stimme wie ein
youtube blogger plötzlich dann habe ich
mir eine stirnlampe geholt weil ich in
meinem badezimmer noch aufräumen möchte
das muss sich wahrscheinlich morgen oder
so machen gar keinen bock drauf aber
davon gibt es glaube ich wieder also ich
glaube ich film das nicht das aufräumen
weil ich das jetzt großen gefallen und
dann habe ich noch ganz tolle
christbaumkugeln gefunden
die sehen aus wie kleine häuser die
hätte man auch selber basteln können
aber konsum
ich finde wirklich schön an der erzählt
ja eigentlich wollten wir noch egal und
sowas kaufen ich gehe aber dann haben
wir irgendwie doch nicht gemacht weil
wir sind da rein und dann beide nach dem
essen sofort müde und wollten einfach
nur nach hause das hab ich noch ein
bisschen weihnachtsbaum das war der
tagesausflug zur ikea gut da der ich
werde dann wie jetzt einmal den block
dann wünsche euch ein
guten morgen es jetzt 22 uhr glaube ich
so eine stunde schlafen gehen und um 36
wieder aufstehen dann werde ich dann
diesen blog schneiden kann
ich bin gespannt ob ich das zweimal
hintereinander shuffle heute morgen ganz
gut geklappt wenn ich ehrlich da war ich
sehr stolz auf mich
kowski